and most people dramatically
underestimate the amount of volume and
effort that is required to get to where
you want to go like dramatically so we
went from seven pieces of content a week
I did three on YouTube and I just
repurposed the same three on a podcast
to 80 content pieces a week and so this
is what happened in those six months we
added 300 000 subscribers on YouTube
seven thousand followers on Instagram
still haven't really cracked that one uh
350 000 on Tick Tock 150 000 buyers
which is cool on Amazon for the buck 350
000 followers on Instagram 100 000 on uh
Twitter and 400 000 downloads a month on
the podcast so basically a million
person audience uh within that six
months